I have to start with the most important
thing right up front were you in charge
of picking the junket location or was it
just because it's right Xavier High
School yes I have done the junket here
once before and that was for an x-men
movie then there was a connection
because of the name of the school but
also it has a beautiful interior as you
can see so no I do live in Brooklyn so
it was much much easier doing a New York
junket than an LA junket for example
completely um I want to start by saying
well the next thing is I really enjoyed
this movie it's so well done I'm curious
if Joe asks you prior to filming - maybe
like watch any movies to sort of get you
familiar with the Tony was looking for
well um I I did some research like I
read a few books and I watched Excalibur
that surpassed reason but they weren't
because this is sort of different any
previous Arthurian legend like to take
so we didn't have any films to watch
that were quite similar to this like
take a look yeah yeah I agree with Louie
I was always a big fan of the Disney
adaptation of the sword in the stone so
I already knew roughly what author and
legend would be like but for me I'm
already at a disadvantage because Sir K
is a man and I'm a female so yeah Lady K
now so I did have to kind of separate
myself from the original legend but for
me that was better because you know
we're making something completely
different completely new there
did you watch anything um III did I had
watched Excalibur because that was the
first large-scale movie that I was ever
in that was 1980 and I I wanted to see
what themes in that movie would overlap
with the themes in Giorgio's script and
they were actually quite a few although
I think Excalibur was a little
but more harsh baths then then kid it
will begin perhaps Joe has a real eye
for casting and he's the one who brought
John boyega to the screen and attacked
the block when you find out you're gonna
be in a movie like this where he clearly
has an eye for casting
what's that reaction like and you know
what I mean
because it's a really big deal I mean
when you get a role like this and Joe
said to us you know like thousands of
kids audition for these parts you just
feel so thankful and grateful and
privileged to have this opportunity that
other kids wouldn't have had yeah but
you also have to give the credit to
yourself when you think about your sight
Wow I laugh so yeah it's just
yeah really grateful really thankful you
might get a career out of this well I
think as rob was what Briana just said
that that she's talking about this
experience but that experience can then
be connected to so many other aspects of
life and school and playtime and work
and so forth and and you can articulate
it so well it was great for each of you
I'm curious about memorable moments from
filming what's like a day or two that
you will always remember
well one moment that I remember was when
we were doing the sword fighting against
the trees and that was when the Knights
are on table learn how to sword fight
and I mean I mean that was actually the
first thing that we shot yeah and that
was that was fun
yeah thing for me it was when we were in
cool and we were on the moors and we
were on the horses and it rained yeah
for the whole time we were shoeing we
were just drenched in it
but then we had a real sunset I believe
in the background so we looked so cool
our armor was glistening even though he
was so wet the horses were wet and
aggravated but Joe was like this looks
so good you don't understand so that was
cool to be a part of something like that
I thought your question applied to any
movies that one had been in no I'll take
I'll take an answer but yes
okay I'll take two instances it's to do
with people I've worked with who I never
thought I would work with right at the
very beginning of my career I did one
whole day's work with Rod Steiger the
two of us sitting in the back of a car
and he was one of my heroes and I could
not believe that I was sharing a camera
with him and the other was Alec Guinness
Sir Alec Guinness you know the great
actor and I did two days work with him
separated by like five years I think and
I would not have exchanged those
experiences for anything
you